It's one of the most dreaded announcements on an airplane.
"Please turn off and stow all electronic devices."
And according to the Wall Street Journal, we may soon hear them a lot less.
Federal Aviation Administration advisers are moving to relax rules...
...against cell phones, tablets and other devices on planes travelling at low altitudes.
But passengers will likely soon have more leeway during taxiing...
...and during takeoff and landing.
The recommendations from top-level FAA advisers...
...follow reports that at least one-third of recent airline passengers...
...say they have "accidentally" left an electronic device on in flight.
The Journal says the eventual goal is to enable e-readers...
...and similar contraptions during entire flights.